[Music]
let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
fall in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
[Applause]
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
I'll fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
sky
[Applause]
e
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
I noticed how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set